[Music]
we're out of coffee oh you're out of
coffee yeah we got no coffee and no
Donuts what do you got ah water
I'm trying to compensate with comedy for
my ineptitude the outtakes for that
Super Bowl spot are Peak Ben his Boston
accent back in full force ET has learned
it's all part of a 10 million dollar
deal with his beloved Duncan JLo earned
just over a million for those 10 seconds
scolding bits that's what you do when
you say you want to work all day I gotta
go guys and we can expect another
commercial coming soon double sausage
turkey sausage egg and cheese maple
sugar bacon black peppercorn are you a
racist I'm coming on blue as for our
other favorite Super Bowl spots hi how
can I help you yeah I don't like the way
you look you look like a flamingo in
this best beat down goes to Bradley
Cooper and his mom Gloria Campana smile
they look like a clam I think I know
what I'm doing I've been nominated nine
times yeah but you never won any best
throwback John Travolta bringing back
Daddy Zuko in this grease tribute scrub
star Zach Braff and Donald Faison his
would-be T-Birds
Ah that's what T-Mobile can
do
[Music]
best where are they now that goes to
Diddy joined by Montell Jordan Donna
Lewis and more your milkshakes cost way
less than before how does the fox say
don't do that some of the biggest
Blockbusters dropped sneak peeks too
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
[Music]
Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton both back
as Batman in The Flash
I'm Batman Guardians volume 3 teasing
the death of Chris Pratt are you ready
for One Last Ride
[Music]